What's going on here, then?
So you are now definitely
going to be standing candidates in every single seat,
is that right?
Yeah. We've been saying this for many,
many months now.
We've made that absolute cast iron commitment. But still
there are a few people who think that we're going to
stand down for the Tories,
who've broken Britain,
who've LED us all down,
who've misled us,
betrayed us on immigration and fighting
things like that,
and haven't done Brexit properly.
So we stand everywhere.
630 seats across England,
Scotland, Wales.
We've got over 440 candidates already lined up.
And we've got a big press conference, uh,
straight back in the New Year on January the third.
We've got our spring conference on the, uh,
February the 24th,
when we'll be showing off lots of those candidates.
So, yeah, we're ready.
We can't wait.
The only thing we.
I think the country is ready is for.
Ready for everything,
to call an election,
as far as I'm concerned.